Willkommen zu einer neuen Episode von Fellow Cast
heute, wir werden einige
Interviews wegen des Moralpsychologie-
Workshops haben, und jetzt, unser erster Gast,
könntest du uns sagen, wer du bist? Ja, mein Name
ist Rihanna Besler und ich arbeite in der
Abteilung für  Wissenschaftsgeschichte und -philosophie
an der University of Cambridge
Schön, schön, Sie kennenzulernen, schön, dass Sie
hier sind. Ja, könnten Sie uns auch sagen,
woran Sie derzeit in der Moralpsychologie arbeiten,
also arbeite ich derzeit hauptsächlich
an Empathie, und daran bin ich besonders
interessiert  wie die wissenschaftliche Untersuchung
von Empathie in politischen
Kontexten in Medizin und Gesundheitswesen verwendet wird und im
Grunde, wie die Forschung, die
aus der wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung von Empathie hervorgeht
, in einer Reihe von verschiedenen
Kontexten verwendet wird, okay, und könnten Sie
uns allen auch sagen, was los ist  Take-Home-
Botschaft Ihres Vortrags, den Sie gehalten haben, oder vielleicht werden
wir ihn in der Zukunft halten. Ja, gestern habe
ich einen Vortrag mit dem Titel Empathie als Fähigkeit gehalten,
und dort habe ich mir die Forschung
zu t angesehen  Die Wissenschaft der Empathie und
die verschiedenen Arten, wie
Wissenschaftler Empathie konzeptualisiert haben,
und ich habe argumentiert, dass es keine
einheitliche Definition von Empathie gibt, sondern dass
es eine Reihe von Fähigkeiten gibt,
die dem zugrunde liegen, was wir
Empathie nennen und  dass dies wirklich
wichtig ist und dass eine neue Art des Nachdenkens
über Empathie, die dies sinnvoll macht
und sowohl die Art
des auf natürlichen Fähigkeiten basierenden Sinns für
Empathie als auch den normativen Sinn für Empathie sinnvoll machen kann, darin
besteht, sie als eine Fähigkeit in der zu betrachten
Dasselbe Gefühl, dass wir
Fahrradfahren als eine Fähigkeit ansehen oder ein ausgezeichneter
Tennisspieler zu sein, als eine Fähigkeit, also in der gleichen
Richtung der Fähigkeit, also ist Empathie
etwas, das wir lernen können.
Ja, ich denke, Empathie ist etwas
, das wir lernen können, aber das ist es nicht  wird
etwas sein, das didaktisch gelehrt werden kann,
also nicht etwas, das
Sie aus einer Vorlesung lernen können, sondern
etwas, das Sie
bewusst üben und auf die gleiche Weise lernen
können  Sie könnten lernen, ein
ausgezeichneter Klavierspieler oder so etwas zu werden
, okay,
was ist Ihr Bildungshintergrund, also habe
ich meinen PhD und meinen Master in Cambridge gemacht,
auch im Fachbereich Geschichte und
Philosophie der Wissenschaften, und davor
ging ich zu einer sehr kleinen freien Kunst
College in Berlin namens European
College of Liberal Arts und das gab mir die
Möglichkeit, einfach viele
verschiedene Dinge in Literatur und
Philosophie zu studieren und einen breiten Hintergrund zu bekommen,
und davor habe ich meinen
Bachelor in Yale in Psychologie gemacht, wo ich
einen gemacht habe  viel Forschung zu visueller Wahrnehmung
und Spracherwerb und
solchen Dingen, okay, also haben wir jetzt zwei
Fragen mehr. Ich würde mich für
Ihre zukünftigen Forschungspläne interessieren, also
scheint es, als hätten Sie eine Grundlage wie
eine Grundlagenforschung zu Empathie geschaffen, also wir  wissen,
dass es etwas ist, das wir lernen können, es ist eine
Fähigkeit wie eine Sache, und was soll dieses
Ziel mögen, warum forschen Sie genau
das und was sind
Ihre großartigen Zukunftspläne?  Eines der Dinge, die mich
wirklich interessieren, ist Empathie und
professionelle Ausbildung, also
denken viele Leute, dass unsere Ärzte
empathisch sein sollten. Viele Leute denken auch,
dass Empathie vielleicht eine Rolle im
Strafrecht und in der Strafjustiz spielt  Die
Idee wäre dann, dass die Täter
von Verbrechen trainiert werden sollten,
ihren Opfern gegenüber empathischer zu sein, und
dass dies eine wichtige Sache für
Anhörungen zur Bewährung und solche Dinge ist, und
daher interessiert mich wirklich,
wie wir über Empathie denken könnten  In
solchen beruflichen Kontexten habe
ich zwei mögliche Projekte, die ich als
nächstes machen könnte. Eines davon handelt von Empathie und
Medizin, im
Grunde was es bedeutet, ein
empathischer Arzt zu sein, und wie wir unseren Ärzten beibringen können,
auf die richtige
Art und Weise empathisch zu sein  und dann geht es bei dem anderen
Projekt um Empathie im Recht, also was macht
Empathie, wer sollte und wer sollte
sich in wen einfühlen, und gibt
es eine Rolle für Empathie in
Gerichtsverfahren s  o Jetzt ist es wirklich
interessant, weil Sie sagten, Sie wollten
erforschen, was wir auf dem
normativen Weg tun sollten. Können Sie uns auch sagen,
wie Ihrer Meinung nach die normative Parole oder
die normative Kernaussage Ihrer
Forschung aussehen könnte, haben Sie bereits
, was wir tun sollten?  dies oder haben Sie,
wie wir sein sollten? Ich habe noch
keine vollständige Antwort auf diese Frage.
Natürlich habe ich noch nicht wirklich
recherchiert, aber dies ist der Zukunftsplan. Ich
habe eher eine Vorstellung davon, was wir
tun sollten  in der Medizin, die ich im Jura mache, also denke ich
, dass es in der Medizin
einige Verwirrung über die Art des
affektiven oder emotionalen Aspekts der Empathie
und die potenziellen erkenntnistheoretischen Vorteile der
Empathie gegeben hat, wenn also Leute sagen, dass sie
wollen, dass ihr Arzt empathisch ist, was
sie wirklich tun  gemein ist so etwas
wie Ich möchte, dass mein Arzt offen ist
und mir eine Art abgestimmtes
Zuhören gibt und dass dies eine
Möglichkeit für ihn ist, mehr Informationen
über meine Situation zu erhalten und das, was mich
nährt  Es geht um die Art und Weise, wie der
Arzt eine Diagnose stellt und
solche Dinge, und ich möchte auch, dass sie
allgemein eine freundliche und fürsorgliche
Art haben, aber ich meine nicht unbedingt, dass
ich möchte, dass der Arzt fühlt, was ich bin
Gefühl, und ich denke, wenn Ärzte
fühlen, was der Patient fühlt, gibt es viele Beweise dafür,
dass er überwältigt werden kann, wenn er fühlt, was der
Patient fühlt, er
könnte ausgebrannt sein und
solche Dinge, und wir wollen
sicherstellen, dass wir Ärzte darin ausbilden  man muss
in einem solchen Kontext die richtige Art von Empathie haben,
und ich denke, die richtige Art von
Empathie wird sehr ausgewogen sein,
also wird es nicht rein emotional sein
, nur mit der anderen
Person zu fühlen, weil das in
den medizinischen
Texten nicht produktiv ist  etwas zu sein,
das keine viel
ausgewogenere Herangehensweise an den Patienten beinhaltet, und
es wird eine Art und Weise beinhalten
, viel mehr Informationen von dem
Schwiegerpatienten zu erhalten, der nicht genau weiß,
was passieren soll  n mit Empathie, also auf der einen
Seite gibt es diese Sorge, dass Empathie
zu Vorurteilen führen könnte, zum Beispiel in
Anhörungen oder Anhörungen des Bewährungsausschusses,
wenn die Person, die
das Verbrechen begangen hat, gezeigt hat,
dass sie
dem Opfer gegenüber nicht mitfühlend ist oder dies nicht tut.  Es gibt keine offensichtlichen
Demonstrationen davon, die die Jury brauchen könnten
, um sie mit einer härteren Strafe
oder so etwas zu belegen, ja,
und das mag eine voreingenommene
affektive Empathie sein, und wir sollten uns
möglicherweise rechtlich darum kümmern, aber
ich denke, dass es andere gibt  potenzielle
Möglichkeiten, wie Empathie in einem nützlich sein könnte
Ich muss mehr darüber recherchieren
Ich bin mir nicht sicher Nein das ist
wirklich interessant Ich würde gerne
auf die medizinische Situation antworten
Könnten Sie auch sagen, dass Ihr Ansatz
dazu ist  ist, dass die Ärzte zuhören sollten
, um den Patienten zu verstehen, aber nicht
nur zuhören, um dem Patienten zu antworten, ist dies eine
mögliche Art, es zu sagen, denn wie
Verständnis macht es möglich,
real zu werden  Vielleicht einfach mal objektiv
die Situation erkennen, in der sich der Patient
mit all den Faktoren und Einflüssen befindet und
dann die richtige Lösung finden, anstatt
wie zuzuhören und wie völlig
unbeeindruckt unbeeinflusst zu sein und ja, also es ist
wie ein Mittelweg, den Sie vorschlagen, es
scheint mir richtig, weil  du hast nicht gesagt
wie der arzt sollte nicht
ganz in das gefühl des patienten gehen und
mit ihm leiden wie ein freund
oder so, aber auch nicht nur
das standardverfahren
richtig machen ja genau das finde ich eine
wirklich nette art  Um es als eine
Art Mittelweg auszudrücken,
Menschen in der Literatur über Empathie neigen
dazu, diese Vorstellung zu haben, dass es
entweder alles emotional ist und es
beinhaltet, sich voll und ganz auf die andere
Person einzulassen, oder dass es nur darum geht
, ihre Überzeugungen zu verstehen und  Wünsche
und dass es sehr kognitiv ist, und ich denke,
dass die Art von affektiven
und kognitiven Elementen auf
wichtige Weise zusammenkommen und dass sie es können
irgendwie ausgeglichen sein und dass wir für die
Medizin wirklich diese Art von
Gleichgewicht brauchen, um da zu sein, also ja, ich denke, dass es sehr wichtig ist,
den Patienten auf einer etwas
emotionalen Ebene zu verstehen, aber auch auf einer Ebene, die
es Ihnen ermöglicht, dem Patienten Informationen zu entlocken,
denn
das ist sehr wichtig  Wenn Sie das auch in Ihre
Diagnose einfließen lassen, haben Sie viel
bessere Informationen, mit denen Sie arbeiten
können, als wenn Sie nur
wirklich knappe Fragen stellen und
sehr schnell eine Entscheidung treffen. Ich denke, dass
Empathie wichtig ist, weil  Es hat eine
Art Informationssammelrolle
innerhalb der Medizin. Vielen Dank und bis
zur nächsten Folge oder anderen
Darstellern